this is an emergency now
it's nothing to do with process they're
just trying to save lives
tens of thousands trying to get through
at the front they're being crushed
paratroopers pulling people from the
mayhem
medics rushing from the next casualty to
the next and the next
all right
dehydrated and terrified
the soldiers spray the crowd with a hose
anything to cool them down
men women and lots and lots of children
[Music]
and then what we feared the inevitable
is this a stabilized withdrawal from
afghanistan
it looks like death to me
in the mayhem units rush through the
crowds to shore up weak points in the
evacuation center
everyone working flat out
trying to stem the tide of an unfolding
disaster
the problem now is not
trying to control the crowds per se it's
the fact that at the front people are
just getting crushed so
thousands of afghans who are coming who
have no right to come here but they're
coming anyway and they they can't just
leave them to get crushed in and the
heat is terrible there's lots of
children so they have to have a sort of
secondary
barrier where people who may have never
get in properly
are at least safe for the time being
it's uh
it just used to go for better worse here
and there's
i don't know
almost speechless as to what they're
going to do about it
[Applause]
it doesn't matter where you look it's
the same desperation
american soldiers pulling children whole
families from the pens they're being
kept behind for processing
these people fear their dreams of a
flight out are ebbing away as each day
passes
soldiers firing in the air they fear
they're losing
control it seems unlikely however a
gunshot is ever going to calm the
frightened down
a narrow street to a compound a press
release say in the uk would take 20 000
afghans and a small group of soldiers
given the job of processing visa
applications while maintaining military
security is morphing into a planning
catastrophe
if it's to be turned round they'll need
time but time is running out
out here pain and compassion meet every
minute of every day now
she will survive but she can't save
everyone
it says it all
stuart ramsey sky news kabul